this guy wally uh out there by mission
hills where i grew up
and he had house sitting for this couple
and they had horses
uh kind of like a ranch style house and
he sold one of their horses
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
directly right
there
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
i think i don't know how different my
life would be if i if i never drank
me and my father are having this
conversation right now yeah he's just
start he asked me that question we like
sat down and had the whole thing and
he's starting to like
not want to drink and it's pretty crazy
i think at some point
it's like
is it fun i mean it's just it goes away
and you do it again and you do it i'm
drinking in my next life okay
i asked that to my i told my pots i was
like
drink is fine i was like but when it
gets to the point where you start to
like change i was like because that's
always with him i was like because he's
like fun it's a great time life of the
party but there's always that moment
like after a certain amount of beers it
just gets like he gets sad about [ __ ]
from like 20 years ago yeah yeah and i'm
like there's nothing we can do about
that is that you two or is that just no
no no no i'm not saying that i'm the
same way [ __ ] man
too much [ __ ] has happened though i
think it doesn't matter think about
people that you love that aren't around
anymore and you've been drinking of
course man yeah you're gonna get a
sentimental i went uh saturday to
reunion for uh guys at work east la back
in the late 60s 70s
guys there with canes oxygen this they
were once warriors but you look around
and you say hey
these guys ain't gonna be around next
year
wow you know there's some old guys there
it was kind of sad
see what they were once vibrant and
going around mighty [ __ ] detectives
but not anymore crime fighters
yeah now they just get on the pull up in
the car
let's go
it looks
looks dangerous
this looks sketchy had me a ball last
night i went to go see momo uh-huh
and i went up on we're at the golden
corral
[Laughter]
at the uh brea improv ooh and they
signed a petition to bring back sir
george's smorgasbord
i remember bringing back more food they
had one right there in pico when i grew
up sir jordan they were great in their
banquet halls
go in there for
baseball ceremonies
work
receptions and then what so what was it
the paranormal thing it was uh the
paranormal thing yeah
it was uh it was fun yeah it was
different that aj is something else yeah
aj
he's amazing paranormal
you guys were he was reading the people
in the audience
yeah yeah yeah do you believe in that
stuff so introduce our guest grandpa oh
yeah
anyway this is actually yours i got a
bunch of gifts by way of intro uh
comedian frank castillo once winner of
roast battle in 2018 something like that
you can tell us
that's a that's like winning the world
series of poker for a comedian yeah it's
not easy to do
it's not is it no making fun of people
because it was like weeks of writing it
was a whole thing
yeah how do you prepare let's see how do
you prepare for that uh
because this is a battle like one-on-one
right and i'm like yeah okay like
singers yeah so for this one for the
tournament it was uh they told you who
you're battling the first week and then
you had a week to prepare and then after
that you had two days because you had to
watch who won and then you had to
prepare from then on and then the finals
you had to write for three people and
that was about four days of writing
so yeah it was it was like a writer's
showcase and um when i won my family
thought it was the best thing in the
world because
you know they're all super mexican and
making fun of people is like that's all
they do like they just roasted the [ __ ]
out of me my whole life so when i went
up on tv and people were making fun of
me i was like yeah my mom says worse
things to me
but yeah it was great but we really do
love to i think it's a way of
it's counter affection
because if they're saying hey
get over here you're a boy like 13 you
got a little titties
and you're like don't call me oh oh how
come
come and look at yourself yeah you
[ __ ] you have that and then they all
start calling you that thousand from
school
let's go my uncle would call me training
bra
[Laughter]
just the worst yeah yeah well there was
also a lot of us there's a lot of
cousins so i was like the middle one so
it was kind of like if you to be noticed
you had to be the loudest or to make fun
of people yeah you were born in el paso
no i was born in san jose california
yeah my family's from los angeles and
then i moved to temecula california and
that's where i started uh comedy when i
was 21. hmm
what was out there drinking that
temecula wine oh yeah yeah it is
a border patrol station and
an indian casino it is and a lot of
white people it is it was very
interesting culture shock for me from
going to like the bay area which was
like a mix of everybody you know i mean
it's a i mean my grandparents used to
work in the fields in san jose so then
to go to temecula where it was like a
military town very safe place right and
then to get stopped by the border patrol
like all the time what's going on over
there in temecula what what dynamic is
that like a more hidden orange county it
is a more hidden orange county is the
best place to raise your kids if you're
white yeah and you don't want to see a
lot of other minorities
if you were white would you like a
mexican living next to you
i don't know i don't know what it's like
living being white
mexicans all around me
you know how to get on the road to being
white have reading glasses and an ipad
and your phone and be just scrolling
your messages put a boston shirt on yeah
they were like calling me mister
mr gill yeah mr gill
is there gills here
yeah yeah so that's cool matt and then
uh um how did you where did you go up
first uh first in temecula that's where
i first went up there was a clip out
there no no it was just bars i was
literally doing stand up in like bars
there's one club it was a pechanga
resort and casino
that's where i would do stand up they i
was a busboy there and i would told them
i wanted to stand up and they're like
sure we'll put you on stage which was a
mistake for them if you think about it
but i still did great and then i moved
to los angeles because that's where i
met um jesus trejo he was like featuring
there a lot and he was just kind of like
if you you're gonna be a big fish in a
small pond or you're gonna move to los
angeles and try to like do it right and
then you told me at the comedy store and
then i moved there became a door guy and
then worked my way up now i'm a paid
regular what are some of the politics or
what are some of the things you don't
have to say names but what goes on in
the in at the co start at the comedy
store
way way back yeah i was 18. i couldn't
really get in you know absolutely put
you up and then put you out like they'd
go
the show would start at eight by eight
oh six i was already outside
and then people were just coming in and
by 906 1006 it was roaring man and i
just saw 11 people you know yeah awful
it was when i got there it was
it was the hardest thing to get in and
also i didn't know this but
a lot of people told me that the store
didn't [ __ ] with mexicans which i had no
idea that that was like uh kind of like
a rumor or like a stereotype um but when
i got in people were just like yeah it's
just really hard to get in so
for the open mics you sign up it's 16
people they pull names out of a hat
there's a few people they pick that they
want to see the town coordinator wants
to see and then you do that for a few
years and then you either get hired as a
door guy or you get passed into the
friends and family which you start doing
development spots and that's just like
spots on different shows throughout the
week but being a door guy there that's
like the main thing because you're like
meeting everybody taking out the trash
you're like putting your time in so i
was there for like six years and then i
got showcased and then i got passed so
there is a lot of politics because
there's people that are outside that
have credits that come in and then they
have to get past because you know
they're killing it on netflix or
whatever and they do deserve to get in
and then there's certain people who like
me who like had to start from the
beginning and then work their way all
the way up and then earned it
wow
yeah is it haunted i absolutely think
it's
yeah because i used to be cereals right
yep cyril's was all the mafia thing i
think that's where frank sinatra punched
some photographer a lot of [ __ ] went
down people got murdered there there was
abortions in the belly room there's a
whole thing is that why it's called that
no but it's pretty terrifying yeah
there's a lot of scary stuff that
happens i think a lot of students are
divorcing i don't know if i believe in
like ghosts and spirits and energies i
do believe in getting absolutely creeped
out when i'm in a room by myself uh so i
never saw anything
there's been like a few times where i've
like walked by a door and seen like a
shadow and like had to like double take
um there's been times where i've heard
things but never like definitive to
where i've been like that's a ghost or
that's a spirit or anything like that
but yeah
definitely been freaked the [ __ ] out
yeah glasses probably drop or if you
hear mumbling that's that's a thing too
mumbling some comics have thrown chairs
while the managers uh been like closing
out to like freak people out
that was a thing that i heard i had a
story about a comic talking about how
like one time they were in the store
they're in the main room and they were
just terrified they heard like laughing
and scratching and stuff and then later
on you'll hear like a comic being like
yeah i followed this person in the main
room when i was scratching and throwing
chairs and you're like oh yeah it is a
lot of drunk people and comics [ __ ]
with people yeah there was a friend of
mine who passed out
in the store and woke up at three in the
morning after everything had been shut
down and he said it was like ice cold he
said he could see his breath when he was
breathing and he had to like climb out
of the second story window because
everything was locked but he says as he
was climbing out he could hear what you
were saying that mumbling like there was
distant conversations in the main room
or like somewhere else in the building
and he was like i had to get the [ __ ]
out of there yeah a lot of bad [ __ ] went
on in there yeah that was that was the
height of i think uh
the rat pack those singers the rat pack
all the great beautiful you know the
place to be seen that sammy davis junior
before all those people performing so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
mexican don't go around stuff like that
you've seen stuff in your house no i
don't see nothing as a matter of fact
they asked me that last night this
paranormal i said no this mexican's
smart enough to say
i'm getting the [ __ ] out you know my mom
was the same way she believes in all of
it but she's also like let's get the
[ __ ] out of here she's like i ain't
trying to hang around yeah over there
especially even if i went in with a
group i'm the slowest one
so i'm the one they're gonna get yeah
what do they say what do they say about
them how do they how do they explain
when
when you see something move or fall or
you see
what is like a [ __ ] shadow of some of
something that's a person like what is
how do you understand
you know i believe it because my house
that had it in my house
and i had
quite a lot in my house what do you mean
like like when i moved in in 2014
i would hear
ma
[ __ ]
what the
[ __ ] was that
right and i heard
another week ma
and i'm like okay there's somebody up
here
i don't know what it is
so i go down and i walk around there's
nobody and right around three o'clock in
the morning which is when it usually
happens
you start to hear
moving things and i saw [ __ ] in there
that was too much for me like i had to
have somebody come in so yeah yeah that
house would have a for sale signing yeah
yeah i know it wouldn't be gayle's house
for lunch yeah like it's it's
creepy dude yeah i mean yeah you got
that big painting that that living room
the the one let me see if i can find
this [ __ ] thing the
the my daughter goes you know there's a
paranormal app on on tick tock and i
said there is and uh paranormal talk
uh and and
and uh it has something that got
something going in front of it and move
and there's no way it could have it
could have been me
so i was kind of okay with what i was
hearing yeah you know and then i started
to see orbs and all that stuff and then
it started to get a little bit
uh on another level and then i i
heard like you know
talking and
uh
computer sounding voices
you know numbers what's that
numbers
what the [ __ ] this is this [ __ ] i'm
driving tesla is that just the yeah sure
it's not the update no i could not no
it's not
it's uh i wish it was
but it got it got a little bit anybody
ever hear anybody having sex in there
you're not involved trying to do that in
there
i don't want to piss them off this ghost
is getting it
but uh yeah
and then i took a uh
they were it was really only on like the
left side down the hall
and all of a sudden i started to
look like i felt
things going like this so
i put the video on and i went
kind of like this one wasn't looking
and uh
there was a there was
like an octagon
in the picture and i said oh what's that
in there and i zoomed in
and uh it was uh oh this is gonna freak
me out my hands are all sweaty look my
hands are already sweating dude it was a
green uh face
in the school in an octagon that wasn't
there
and
that's what i said i think this is i
think it's time like yes
because they're getting now they're on
both sides i only felt one on one side
and then now they're on both sides
that's
that house is
who owned it before do you know any
history of the house you know i think it
was just these people had it for a long
long time and then it didn't have many
owners maybe threes it's from the 20s
that's classic ghost
but you know the the what the lady said
is you know they by griffith park they
travel across and they look they look
for places to kind of
get aj and momo to go down there they uh
almost been down there and momo um
you know almost pair he's got he's got
a feel for it too mumbo does and um
when momo when mom was at my house you
were in that room upstairs and he goes
uh
[Music]
who called you in canto
i said well
what did you say who called you encanto
i said
where did you where did you hear that he
goes no right now like it just came into
my head my grandfather used to come
there
and that's something nobody would know
yeah see when [ __ ] like that happens i'm
always just like how the [ __ ] because
there's always sometimes people like
cold read or whatever
yeah when it's small it's like very
specific all right i'll be right there
george i gotta go yeah
they give me kills
we'll give you something we'll give you
some smoke on the way out to make sure
that nothing nothing sticks to you
but
you know
i think when in mexican families yeah
that's that's believed a lot
right but you don't know culturally yeah
and then just things that
you just hear man like
also like spiritually and like going on
and stuff like
yeah my mom always just be like
grandma's still with us grandpa's still
with us you know our family members are
still with us
i'm julian you're founding out your mom
and dad
no no you know last night they uh they
tried to read you aj
says can i read you before you're going
yeah i don't care
and so he starts telling him about he
says i see a man he's an an adult man he
says it's not your father
your father-in-law
and
you had a father-in-law and he's
and somehow july is very prevalent
in in this uh the july was july's
birthday i said no but that's his name
was julio that's what everybody called
him july
oh yeah
and i said okay
and he says uh he couldn't communicate
he wants you he's using you
to tell your wife he loves her
very much he's doing okay and he knows
he couldn't communicate with her in the
end
well he had alzheimer's and
he you know he was he was gone and then
he couldn't he went in a coma
and so
that was uh
he had a couple of people three people
on the other crying a bunch of people
audience and what is that man crying
intuition or what is that what are you
born with
at one point in time even when we were
talking i was on stage and i moved a
little left to momo i was you know like
hey that's i'm getting too close to you
brother and then i'm over here with aj
and aj starts out and i'll move back
over here in the middle
because they were talking
especially aj he he reached out and
got some lady to talk i see a boy
a boy
and the month of january comes up and
and it's not a big boy he's about five
years old and and is there anybody here
and some lady up front says hey mexican
she says
she raised her hand she says
my son he says that your son passed you
said yes
and
he would be five years old today
and he says wow he says that he said
wait a minute name starts with the
e-r-a-r well the guy's name was like
aaron or
ernie and i'm saying holy geez she's
crying he does a stuff with her lady
next to her and i'm saying these are
mexicans they're not you know they're
not shills they're just they're just
there she got it huh yeah and then
he starts talking to her
and
heard about her father
and he had a graveyard well he died at
cancer and he died in this month and had
a message you know
and the mother used to boss him around
and everything was right and she was
crying worse than the mother of the
five-year-old
i mean and and there were other people
in the audience i'm sitting right in
there you see him crying just going
going through this
there was one lady i reached over to
momo
ah
no it's holding up a picture that's
weird creepy ass shadow face
that was in the corner of that picture
and this is the paranormal here it is
so
the thing that's in front of the screen
is not that steep
and watch this how it moves
see that's not my finger watch this
do you see that
it just kind of it just moves away
because i'm holding the camera with this
hand that means i would have to go like
this but that's not
missing
so the okay the yellow that the yellow
is the
meter and then there's that and then it
goes away oh yeah yeah
oh man i'm thoroughly creeped out now i
like how i was like do you believe in it
i was like no and then like 10 minutes
later i'm like all right now i'm
terrified
it's got it's got to be something if
it's energy or if it's uh whatever you
your parents were and your family wasn't
into that [ __ ] oh absolutely they were
my grandma
absolutely yeah my mom does the sage she
does everything yeah yeah yeah
oh no i'm good i'm actually gonna
so frank brought a uh a grab bag of
goodies here oh yeah i have uh
everything how did you get into the how
did you get how did you get into the
weed oh i'll explain that right now um
so i've always just been a huge fan of
it yeah and uh when i got my first
manager he told me he was like you
should lay off the weed stuff
and i was like all right um but now was
that our mutual friend that was our
mutual friend and then um now
i've just been a fan of these these guys
specifically punch extracts and puffco
um they've saw me do stand-up and then
we kind of just reached out and then
they talked about reading your standard
no no i just i'm a huge i just do a lot
of wheat so these brands a lot of weed
brands pay influencers like thousands of
dollars
for like posts and stuff and i was just
like i do stand up just pay me and i'll
just you know what i mean because i
already use the products already and i
love them and i stand by them so yeah
that's how i got into weed i've always
been into weed if i wasn't a comic i'd
have just been uh working in a
dispensary uh um what what is um
what are the benefits of of it like you
does it mail you out does it
can you can concentrate an hour before
you really
you i never felt like for me it was like
um
like my whole family drinks so like the
weed for me it's like i could do weed
and still be fine especially when i do
stand up yeah because i have naturally
i'm anxious anyways i have natural
anxiety so whenever i do weed i'm like
oh okay i'm just stoned wow yeah that
does help and you know it helps me a lot
yeah what what do you think it was that
finally made it go over the
over the top like getting being
legalized in in all these states
i think it was when a lot of the people
especially like cancer patients and like
the actual medical benefits because
aside from everyone that just loves
smoking weed
there's actual benefits medical balance
for people that are like
have cancer or like problems and stuff
like my wife's um aunt has really bad
arthritis we went on a um oh no here
just taking a look here yeah
infused malt balls
goblin yeah
um like my uh
wife's aunt's like 75 she's got bad
arthritis she hates taking pills yeah i
gave her some edibles yeah she's the
best sleep she's ever had same thing
with my pops i'm trying to get him to
stop drinking and do more edibles
just because he likes that feeling of
being under the influence but it's like
with edibles the worst thing that's
going to happen you're going to spend a
bunch of money on food yeah right yeah
you do edibles too right i do edibles
yeah would you what's your nat what do
you usually do like the most
well 20.
i'll do 100. you will you do 100. i'll
do 100 right now
what do you what do you need here's the
mall
yeah
absolutely
come on
you know
you go in the car for a cuddle
[Laughter]
it tastes a little better
it's good it's like
whoppers that's that's new i love that
idea
so many of these things do not taste
good um i sleep i sleep good at night
using those the last batch you gave the
qingon ones they're good the one who got
the golfer yeah they're good right yeah
so
these guys came to me and they said well
you know what what do you what what do
you see
that's not out there right now like i
didn't this is this was a few years ago
i said how about like um
you know bix with cbd thc yeah and uh we
we did it yeah so the vix is already
mentholated so it goes deep and then it
takes those it takes that with it yeah
it's almost like i gave that to one of
my hands too that's like stuff like that
is
that so important
and you know good i use that and and and
you know you you when be real was in
here you know you're like hey i don't do
it you know never did it because when
you said you were a sheriff it was a
felony absolutely
so has that
still with me
too like
you know i'm older like you and then you
think you're going to get in trouble
like yeah you guys are going to get in
trouble no i mean your generation had
all the propaganda you guys like it
ended people's careers and like i think
there's still people in jail now yeah
sure yeah and i just said i i'm not a
prude i don't give a [ __ ] who does just
that old stigma because it was so long
i don't do it my doctor's the one when i
asked myself what about this [ __ ] for
arthritis
and he says hey i buy that stuff for my
mother yeah well you know that's when i
started use now i use the vix one
when you see when you see people with
chronic pain
and they go to the doctor and they give
you prilosec
a can a problem a bottle of product
second a bottle of [ __ ] narcos or
anything with that [ __ ] your stomach up
like yeah it's like chalk in your
stomach and you you can't pass them all
and they give you this because it's
going to disrupt your stomach and now
you're doing these and you're getting
addicted
and with that right yep it doesn't yeah
and then now there's also like there are
people with cancer patients like my
friends know all the correct terminology
and i know they're going to scream at me
for [ __ ] this up but so most people
get raw cannabis and they'll like boil
it down or they'll like make it to where
it's like a paste so you can get the
actual not thc a there's an actual
cannabinoid that like helps shrink the
cancer so that's and but you have to eat
like the paste of it that's just
concentrated to you cannabinoid that's
another new word
yeah the cannabinoid is what so there's
like a lot of education when it comes to
weed like uh when it comes like everyone
thinks it's like sativa or indica so the
best way here's another [ __ ]
marijuana that's that's sharp yeah like
be real yeah be real they were in there
smoking like you know you guys smoke all
day or eat all day and then come in here
and say what was like what was i gonna
tell you
they they know so that that's a yeah so
a lot of people think weeds all sativa
and indica as well back in the day it
was a lot of it's uh the terpene profile
so like whenever terpene profiles like
flowers because that's what wheat is
weeds of flowers so like um you ever
smell weed and it's nice
you ever smell flowers you're like oh
this smells fruity or whatever same
thing with the weed so like certain
terpenes affect you specifically so like
some people like to feel calm when they
smoke so they'll smoke sativa when
reality it's a specific terpene it's
like the lemon flavor or lemon smell
that calms you same thing with like
different strains and stuff so yeah so
it's all like yeah it's all flowers man
but it's all it's all kind of scientific
too now a lot of it is scientific so
there's actual buildings where people
like guys like my cousin who've been
growing weed his whole life and was
getting in tons of trouble now that it's
legal people are looking for growers
like big brands with tons of money um
we'll look for people to be like hey i
have grow houses we really don't know
anyone that's qualified and then my
cousin walks in he's like i've been
doing this for years and now he's got a
legit job you see that's real that's
real work like us we would be like hey
what would happen if a [ __ ] dog
leave me all your conversations but you
know that was that was our [ __ ] now they
got scientists doing it in ours you know
yeah oh yeah you know torturing a
[ __ ] bird
it's awesome i'm glad i'm glad we came
up for those days but then a lot of it
was bad a lot of it was a lot yeah well
because i mean like anything there's
still people like there's the
unregulated market which are people like
you know like you know people just
trying to get by and there's also people
still trying to cut corners and
make a quick buck so there's like a
thing that was happening in the
underground market where people were
cutting
concentrates with like
wood sap so it looks like concentrates
and then you go home and you're like oh
this is just
like rubber oh yeah you know because
people try to get over on people all the
time and that's where it becomes
dangerous where it's like if you're
buying stuff from
the unregulated market you might get bad
product as opposed to buying stuff from
the legitimate market but even then most
the legitimate companies some of them
aren't following the correct standards
is there a um
fda of marijuana uh they so there are
there's a few like there should be
though right there should be there's
that way yeah that way you can get a
handbook and figure figure it out but
the problem that's happening now is
since this is all a new market and these
are all starting to get built a lot of
the people that are building those
things like the oversight committees
those are all people like that are in
the pockets of other people that are
getting paid for yeah it's pretty crazy
to see it's like when they send when
they send you things to vote that
two-page thing on the cardboard and you
go oh these are pretty good and you look
at the buff sponsored by yeah yeah yeah
safe america yeah yeah uh yeah and then
and most people would follow that
because it's all the box is big you
don't have to think you read it a little
to the bottom who's paying for it is
exactly exactly yeah yeah
what's going to happen in the weed
coming up is going to be insane like
there's going to be a lot of
legit companies jumping into the weird
world like there's beer companies that
are going to be starting to make like
thc like seltzers and such yeah there's
someone making like i think it's sumo
snacks they're making a thc snack line
so it's like doritos cheetos stuff that
are not like chocolate or like gummies
right it's wild to say
and those things are going to go into i
think whole foods or pavilions cvs is
selling uh cbd creams already
and it's better than i mean it doesn't
work it doesn't i mean
i've tried the cbd it does nothing it
depends on which ones you get because
that's the thing too is like a lot of
the cbd that's out there is like not
either enough or regulated so it's just
like you know people just like this is a
thing try it and then the placebo effect
happens but it's come a long way in a
short amount of time maybe in 10 years
right where you would go to some place
and there was a doctor you'd go and see
them and you'd go and go because how you
guys doing pretty good what you can't
sleep no i can't i can't sleep you got
pain in your back yeah okay
yeah
right and they couldn't regulate that no
no he's got a tie-dye shirt on and
everything like yeah bob marley's
playing he's like yeah yeah they would
write you uh 50 bucks or what 40
whatever they'll write you a card now
you can go get it yeah
lax put out that thing saying that if
you fly out of la
with under six grams or an i think two
ounces of weed they're not going to stop
you
tsa is not going to stop you because
they're just like they're worried about
more important things but if you're in
another state where it's illegal and
you're leaving the airport then it's a
whole different situation yeah wrong
yeah
and how does he do it with uh
considering like driving under the
influence is there a way
i know
i don't know what they do because all
this [ __ ] came out before now they're
they're doing a little war
i i know but i don't know what they're
doing
in order to test them you know yeah i i
haven't heard how can you tell when
someone's driving high i mean i
i mean i'm not gonna confirm nor deny
that i drive stone but uh hypothetically
i did i drive very very safely
you do drive safe you can't you you do
that did you make the bent actual
studies
feels like cushier you're like i'm
focused on the road my favorite song's
playing yeah i dude i let people in
yeah i didn't cut anybody off
i don't know what
they did should we hot box skill in here
what's that they start burning
here's the thing that i think that
because
i know how much
older people are in pain like you know
how much pain they endure oh yeah uh to
the point where even if you thought if
they if they walked a little bit and
they can't they're saying i can't walk
but they they're leery of
of weed and thc and different products
but they should but they shouldn't be
i'm saying
if you're still if you're older or
whatever age and you have chronic pain
and you're taking pills and you've never
tried this i would say
to try it you'd be smart to try it
absolutely and it doesn't even have to
be smoking weed because that's what yeah
like that's the biggest thing that i
always run into especially with like my
wife's family
they're like well i don't want to inhale
smoke right that's like well there's
vaporizers there's edibles there's
there's a whole smorgasbord right things
that you could take to um get what you
need you know
it's almost to the point just from a
non-user
smoking is still
to me you know the stigma yeah oh that's
the bad stuff
but i don't bat an eye now for comfort
to do the gummy bear
the the thc good
i don't i don't know if
anybody doesn't like it they can kiss my
ass
but you found some relief in that right
pearl too yeah yeah it's and that's the
biggest thing is watching people find
the relief and be like oh okay it's not
like how i thought you know like i
smoked weed with an aunt of mine who's
been up my ass my whole life about
smoking weed and i was like i just i had
a vape pen that i was just hitting and
it doesn't look like a regular vape pen
it's just cool looking it's an alien
labs like green one i wish i brought it
but um
she hit it twice and was just like oh
this is it it's like yeah this is what
getting stone is like now like we're
just having fun yeah she's like oh okay
and when i use it for pain once again
it's not like you turn on the switch and
then five minutes now you realize hey
the pain's gone no
you know somebody asked you hey how's
your finger doing
oh i feel normal didn't even notice yeah
but it's just not painful right now yeah
but don't get me wrong i love getting
absolutely wrecked like i still love
that's like my favorite how much does it
take you to get wrecked me now um dude
what do you mean like 200 milligrams
like so how many of these have you taken
so i'll do a hundred of these and i can
walk around i'll be fine you know
because we do 100 we do 100 on our
podcast um but if i do 120 to 150 i feel
every 10 milligrams of that like i feel
i can really feel it um
dabs i'll do a bunch smoking weed i just
i'll smoke and i'll go on stage
absolutely wrecked and but that is fun
to me because
normally when i'm on stage i'm just kind
of like oh the set's got to go good am i
doing this new joke blah blah but when
i'm like stoned and up there i'm like
i'm in front of people and i just want
to have fun like i want to be silly i
want to make people laugh and then like
i'm in the moment and i'm just having
more fun yeah it works yeah yeah yeah
cause don't go wrong there's times where
i'll be stoned and i'll be like oh this
person's watching me or like someone
really someone i really respect or like
an agent or something but then if it's a
full room and i'm just high i'm like oh
i'm just gonna have fun who cares
yeah
and i think and i think that uh
i think our culture has been like either
for or against nobody's in our culture
nobody's on the fence about anything
[ __ ] yeah i like that guy
[Music]
i think we need to help ourselves
because
you know they're afraid they're they're
maybe they're shy they don't know how to
go into a place and ask for things oh
but if they did it would change
everything well well fortunately for me
uh i use it you know i don't know if
it's an excuse or not there's a purpose
you know i want to be comfortable i want
don't don't want pain i'm not used to to
get i want i want to get high i'll go to
a bottle of wine you know start drinking
wine start drinking whiskey whatever i'm
my alcohol of choice but i think if you
if you started to get high i think
you wouldn't even know it until half the
bag was gone but you and the dog would
be eating from the same chips yeah
absolutely
[Applause]
my aunt called me and was like uh i wish
she would stop smoking weed and i was
just like i had to tell her how much
money i made off of weed this year and
then i had to tell her i was like what
would what do you think it'd be like if
you didn't drink at all and only smoked
weed and she was just kind of like oh
[ __ ] because she's only drank her whole
life right so it was just so funny to me
that it was just like hey you guys my
family has such strong opinions yet i've
seen them drink their whole lives
getting into fights arguments all this
stuff i was like me my cousin smoked
weed our whole lives it was like we
don't get into trouble but it's also
like a a soothing agent like you
if you eat like a gummy and then you uh
drink a little bit and you eat another
one but it'll keep you from going over
the edge because it makes you feel
satisfied so now you're just kind of
having enjoying the drink instead of
trying to put it away exactly you stay
on a nice even
yeah that putting away that's something
that's something i've had to explain to
like
i mean i haven't done it a lot but it
works when i do it yeah yeah that
putting away thing i've had to explain i
was like yeah that whole like putting it
away like i got like my family will kill
a 24-pack like that's their whole thing
they're like we got the 36-pack we got
to kill it yeah that's just that's how
they've always been
yeah
i've been like
and and i don't
you know even dude you know although not
comedic wise you know i've spoken in
front of like large large groups
uh i'm calm relaxed i'm fun and and and
i'm funny i don't need
being last night uh i went up on stage
on two bottles of water
yeah and
it was all good this is an intervention
not at all and like i said in the
beginning i'm no prude i don't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care if my kids do it you know
what whatever it's not my life it's
theirs yeah so so gail you know we just
we just met earlier this year like he
did the night stalker yeah you know
yeah and and
his life was so different up until the
documentary came out and i think the
last 10 months have been yeah i saw that
car did they give you that from the
netflix dog because that thing's insane
no that's mine okay
i hold that to myself a big man
but you know he uh
you know he got out of the house he got
you know he started coming in just as a
guest and we got along and i'm like hey
mike you know come in here and have a
good time met people he didn't think he
would meet
no they they really didn't
and and i can still remember bobby lee
the first time i came in here i had no
idea it was going to be a podcast
because all he told me was hey come on
down hang around here's the address we
get there around two o'clock
and so i came in here and all of a
sudden hey this is a podcast that's
great that's the best way to do it and
so he did it and bobby lee said are you
nervous coming down here
and you're going to meet george i said
no no i wasn't nervous at all i was
excited because i had paid
good money to see george at least five
different events
and now i get a chance to meet
these celebrities and plus we had talked
on the phone it was just nice and since
then
uh
you know i get
messages that people really uh
enjoy the program and they like it and
hey you and george work good together
and i tell them all the same thing hey
you know what thank you very much i'm
glad you enjoyed the program but nobody
enjoys as much as i do being here it's
fun
it's fun and there isn't that's what
makes a beautiful podcast is that
relationship right there is the fact
that you're also not in this comedy
world but you're also having a legit
great conversation with someone who's
hilarious and knows how to like you know
dictate the conversation he does but
also you are such a great
point of view because you are in a sense
the audience you are right the person
that's watching the show they can relate
the most to you because you are the you
know the
i don't say normal person but you're the
every man and that's great to watch i've
been watching all the episodes i love it
i'm very fortunate
to be a part of it and uh d.l hughley
yeah said he listens to
almost every one of your podcasts
and he said you and george together
are really good he's just mixed he says
and and and he was honest he says you
know he told me he says you know he said
i gotta be honest with you i don't like
cops
he said but you
you're different you know you and george
you complement each other and you ain't
never done this [ __ ] in here and
naturally you know you just talk you go
and it doesn't
matter so it's it's just
fun and i'm just flattered and honored
to be here you remind me so much of my
family like you remind me dead on like
my uncle because my uncle's the same way
he's put him in any kind of situation
socially he knows how to talk to people
he's got stories he's he's great to get
along with he can keep the ball moving
um yeah so that's just so yeah you're a
great fit for this hey do they have a
club that is more for weed and weed
comedians like i've always
i think that would work i've said that
there needs to be a weed friendly club
it doesn't need to be only weed right
the problem is people you can't sell
alcohol and weed at the same place but
if there was like uh just a venue where
it was like you could bring wheat in you
can smoke they have some comedy clubs at
dispensaries that are like that which i
think would be great it's fun you know
um be white but yeah i think that's
another thing somebody uh said they go
to the laker games one of the guests on
here i don't know
they go to the laker games and they'd
smoke up on top
you know like their own little oh yeah
yeah but i don't remember which dog yeah
i can't remember which guess it was
well you know some guys used to
take a cigarette and take the tobacco
out and put cocaine in it and put it
back in there and
smoke it at half time really
now that i say cocoa puff i think the
person up there if you hear he hears he
knows it will be him
pretty good by the way all right yeah
oh dude i got actually i got
pretty good this whole bag can i sleep
with this or is this a wake up one no no
these are all see this is all for you
but yeah you could go ahead and look
through those i got bars and stuff come
on with them yeah throw your [ __ ]
bikini
[Laughter]
i'm not afraid of you i'm afraid of the
house brother
the [ __ ] devil isn't there no man
just give the house some edibles it'll
be fine i think i should leave them out
you see the shadow but instead it's like
this one
you walk in your kitchen you're like oh
my god it's been haunted oh wait and
there's just food everywhere there's
like other things is that me or is that
yeah it's made a sandwich but it it um
you know i'm impressed with how far it's
coming it's short oh here's a cream here
open that one girl let's see oh that all
looks great great packaging too man
that's uh that's uh that's strawberries
and cream oh strawberries
no these are awesome
and great um
the great packaging too oh yeah punch is
great they've really they've been
supporting me since day one so they're
all good dudes too yeah yeah this is
super also i think
there's a lot of mexicans that work for
the company too so it's pretty great
yeah they
you know they were they used to
where they used to grow strawberries
they're growing uh weed now i used to
have a joke about how
yeah yeah absolutely i used to have this
joke about how like how mad do you think
uh like
mexicans that work the fields found out
about like white people trimming weed
they're like they're doing what in
oregon
you could just trim and smoke wheat what
are we doing down here right and they
know how to do it just you know like
absolutely
like there's one little thing here
there's uh so
they're
a lot of uh
college kids will go up to the up north
and they'll trim for the season they'll
make their money in the comeback they
call them grins it's terrible
yeah because they mo they oh it's a
bunch of white kids that go up north to
yeah it's so dumb um but
what started happening is there's uh
groups of like
like it's kind of if it's vietnamese
people but these farms are starting to
get groups of them to come up and
they'll like a hundred of them will show
up they'll trim for like half the cost
and it'll be like families and they'll
just be making rice and stuff and
they'll camp out for the months and it's
like crazy how much they're just
murdering uh the whole
that's great i think you have to look at
what you're growing and all of a sudden
say you know we don't [ __ ] around with
this then we could be doing this yeah
i'm you know i don't know how much more
but time more times the money that you
said cream i thought this was i thought
it was good
strawberries and creams
there's no cream in here right no corn
that's all milligrams 10 milligrams of
thc how much does that do oh no that's a
hundred uh each little square is ten
right oh okay and that's rosin explain
roger gill right so even though i don't
know i'll [ __ ] put that
explains
rub it on your head before you pitch so
that's concert that's what you put in
this um
so that is solventless it's basically um
heat water and pressure so they get weed
they freeze it and you know they have a
little crystals that's the thc yeah they
put it in ice baths and they just beat
it and all the crystals fall they push
it together with heat and it makes that
and you smoke it and it just lights you
up
and they put that in joints too
yeah the dab is that what the yep
i got you one that's what this thing is
which is incredible how do you use that
one let's see just double tap it and
then you hit it
do you want to show you yeah all right
i'll use mine
with the light in this if i choose
mighty windows they [ __ ] think of
everything yeah dude in my day we would
have said why don't we put a light in
there the next one nobody would [ __ ]
remember this is bluetooth dog this
hooks up to your phone
it's yeah this thing is yeah
don't toy with a [ __ ] that's
easily influenced yeah yeah no it's it's
great it connects to your phone and
everything so these guys puffco
clapton big fan of them they've
supported me
right now
well no he's like close with the people
who uh
and also and also i may say
that it's a different shape than
i like the shape of it do you want me to
set you up no are you sure because i'd
be
i don't know he hit it before he came on
and you can see him already hey by the
way did you know it's been working
today's grant's birthday i didn't know
that oh yeah today is grant's birthday
and the little store that i just opened
up
thank you very much but people still i
think are afraid of it right yeah well
it's just a stigma people are like ah
but it's
does it help can it help slow
things i mean dementia alzheimer's or uh
there have been studies that it has
helped
if they did that would be bad that's
good
if
they have done studies but if weed was
able to full on like treat and help and
cure alzheimer's i think that would be
an insane breakthrough that i i think
that would be one of the things that a
lot of people wouldn't be able to deny
or like be like weeds terrible right
yeah
in denver when they were they were the
first ones uh yeah one of the first ones
in the world they did it right i mean i
think they they said kind of the way the
other states would work yeah like
everybody thought that people would be
in the streets don't mind them you know
yeah laid out but nothing it's all very
important everyone's at home passed out
yeah yeah
yeah yeah legalizing everybody's
by the way i got a request uh i guess
the raiders are going to play the
broncos
yeah and
somebody said get your tacos
get your taco wagon up there again to to
uh to the stadium yeah
come and feed the raiders yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
brand new stadium sold out
loose of the bears
at least the lost look nice
yeah they got they got a nice
they had a nice team i mean you know
but you could see it i think because of
the the john gruden thing i think that
yeah
is uh
got people a little bit off there
because all everybody was thinking about
there
what happened with him was like leaked
emails or something like i was like yeah
i think it was linkedin an email was
talking about one of the guys in the in
the union
[Music]
we're gonna get in trouble for emails
from 10 years ago
oh
be in
minus the sugars and cream or
strawberries
yeah yeah but no i i think uh
john boehner the guy that speaker of the
house he
he helped get it passed and then he
bailed and it just all he does is weed
now yeah
right
yep i mean if we was i mean i think the
main issue that should happen is
everyone that's in jail for
weed still should be let go well they
just uh they just announced on the news
they're gonna sponge a bunch of them
yeah let them out of jail yeah which is
great what if you had it was weed was
your third strike where they let you out
it was non-violent they probably
wouldn't have done it anymore anyway
yeah i don't know if i'd go so far as
letting a bunch of people out you know
it was
at some time it was uh depending on what
they're doing and they
a lot of people would plead
to possession as opposed to
pleading dealing yeah so in the prison
system somebody goes in there let's say
they get six years and it's the goal in
the six years to
have them adjust to living in life when
they get released of not being a
criminal well everything is toward built
towards rehabilitation with the
exception of the death penalty
and you can tell who's going to be
some guys can and some guys can't
get out they
they get out
they go back to where they grew up or
where they live exactly they're one of
the same bad people there exactly
you get people you know we've moved
people out of state you know that
became informants you know they they
rolled over and saved themselves so they
move them out of state but give them
about six months and they're right back
in the bottle you know they miss it this
is what this is all they know there was
a i was playing golf in uh
uh arizona at a country club and these
guys sitting around they go hey there's
scott and they go scott come on meet
somebody
it's a little guy
about five three
italian guy big rolex hey zeus guys
this is joe hey nice to meet you man
what is that for gays let me see that
watch is that for gazing clearly a
mobster who went into the witness
relocation
[ __ ] lives in arizona hey i'll take
it easy guys
that's scott's a good guy that
[ __ ] sent me the ball
[ __ ]
tammy the bulls
they're out there like and now he's come
out of hiding yeah man griselda blanca
owns a taco shop in [ __ ] new
hampshire right now
you [ __ ] do like
that's not that dude's background yeah
first thing he said about the watch hey
is that a for gazi let me see that thing
you're like jeez yeah
i mean they can't fly under the radar
like that a guy like that's not gonna
well no sam eventually just came out he
didn't give a [ __ ] about anybody anymore
but there's a lot of people yeah and
let's go let's go through it do you ever
know i've met anybody in the wilderness
relocation program have i ever met
anyone in the witness okay no no no no
they can't say if you did they weren't
doing their job
but is there a way to tell if somebody
in the one of these neighborhoods if
you're living next to somebody who would
suck because you have to because you
have to get a new name and a new
identity i haven't found anybody in the
witness protection program living back
here in la county you know we normally
yeah we just move them away get them out
of out of state but they they all come
back this is all they know yeah you know
it's their life you know
all of a sudden if they took you out of
comedy
and put you in arizona said you can't do
anything anymore that's oh yeah you know
you mean last year
how did you get through the pandemic oh
man threw a lot of wheat but um when the
pandemic hit it sucked for me because i
lost my job at the store and then i was
supposed to go on the road
um and do theaters with bert kreischer
yeah and then uh that all got cancelled
but it made me figure everything out and
now i'm fine
like i started the podcast got all these
things working and then it made me make
the next step which was quit in the
store and then trying to be a headliner
and make money on your own the store is
a big deal huh it's
when you get passed you have to quit
it's like it's okay it's it's not
they don't make you but it's implied
like all the other door guys kind of
like they're like hey you're like the
senior that's still hanging around and
but also like getting passed doesn't
solve your problems like you make a
little money doing stand-up there but
like you know you don't make
what you were making work in the door so
there's a whole infrastructure there to
set up and it's been like that for years
right absolutely i didn't know i didn't
know yeah so the or when you work there
i think you get so you get paid think 25
bucks but when you do the main room you
split the door so depending if it sells
out you can actually make a living off
that which is great
but if you're a young guy like me you
don't get a lot of main room spots all
the time you'll get them here and there
so it's hard to be like consistently be
like i'm making money off this
but now that i'm like touring and
headlining you know trying to move
tickets i mean as stressful as that's
ever been it's the most fun i've ever
had oh yeah it's great because it's i'm
finally doing my own thing like my whole
family kind of doesn't quite understand
this
but like you know they all have the nine
to five mindset which is fine but this
is like you know you know it's like
being comic you gotta it's every day
all the time yeah
i had no idea how tough it was i was
talking to momo about it last night and
listening to you i had no idea oh yeah
this is everything you had to go through
and what you oh yeah yeah the store
especially six years it was like college
yeah and there's some times that you
you're not having a good day you don't
you know you got to get yourself to that
place but oh that's my wife has been a
godsend she's uh she's got her masters
in psychology she is a psychologist but
through this whole thing we've been
together for like 10 years she's really
been my rock that's amazing there's been
so many times where like i've been
broke crying on the street like i i want
to quit and then she's just like nah you
got to keep doing it and then you know
now we're in a better place yeah but
yeah no it gets dude it gets tough
yeah it's
if you're on tour like that if you're
touring with musicians but comedy too
it's it's because
those days get
those days get shorter
you know when you're going from like
town to town or or traveling in the
middle of the night to get to some the
next place
you know you get out of bed it's
kind of have lunch it's like two o'clock
you take a little nap and it's time to
go like your day is that
that big yeah what was it like when you
came up in the scene
especially being like you know i feel
like one of the only mexicans at the
time yeah yeah paul rodriguez was at the
was that the comedy store yeah he was
and uh i saw him maybe like in 19 i
might have been 79 but i saw him in
82 and he popped in and he had this
leather jacket and looked good man it
was funny as [ __ ] man it was all
attitude so me and my buddy ernie left
i looked at him and i said man can you
imagine by the time i get that good that
dude's gonna be [ __ ] that good
but he was never really a guy who worked
on his act or never really wrote he just
kind of would wing it you know sometimes
he did great sometimes he wouldn't do
great but he was winging it he didn't
really write stuff but he was clever
yeah but he'd never really never really
wronged so i think a little bit catches
up to you if you don't write and you're
just trying to you're just trying to
swing for the fans and now he's going
one of these days i'll be up there
yeah like you that's one of those things
that uh was stressed to me when i was
working the store was like right they're
like right right right neil brennan told
me he goes the most successful comedians
are the ones they're writing every day
and uh jessalyn i wrote this down after
he said he goes you want to be
a stand-up that writes not a writer that
does stand up right because when i after
rose battle i tried my hardest to get
into a lot of roast writing rooms or
writing jobs and it just never panned
out and i it weighed on me so much like
it it beat myself up because the whole
thing was like like we need diversity we
need diversity i'm like i'm a mexican
guy that [ __ ] murdered on tv like why
am i not in these rooms like my packets
are great and then you realize there's a
lot of politics when it comes to like
writer's rooms and and just the industry
so that's kind of why i wanted to get
into weed was because i was like oh i
can just write sketches or write for
these brands and they'll treat me better
instead of trying to that's true
sacrifice myself and get into these
rooms and then not do standards right i
applaud you for your following your
convictions absolutely yeah sure yeah
you should be proud of yourself so the
roast battle
um do you know what a rose battle is we
explain the guilt
oh okay so it's two comics going head to
head they do about three to five jokes
each uh it's just back and forth it's
like you know the dozens back in the day
but
with the comics they tell you who you're
going against so you have about a week
or two to prepare so for me i would do
research i'd like figure out who i'm
going against learn everything about
their family learn like your
insecurities like just just learn about
them right and then the more information
i have the better i am at writing a
better roast joke and then that's just
it got to that point where i would
write about 100 jokes cut down to 20 and
then i would have my 12 jokes that i was
gonna do
some throwaway lines
and then yeah i just come in prepared
give them an example give us an example
of oh one of uh all right one of my
favorite ones was uh
i was battling uh a friend of mine who's
a uh
now now a woman uh back then was gay uh
and i'm and i feel like i just canceled
myself uh anyways uh but uh joe dosh was
the personals battling and
i said their forehead is so big
uh because it gives them more rooms to
think about dicks
just dumb [ __ ] like that uh i said uh i
was battling jay light who's this white
kid i said um he's so white that he
forgets to cash his paychecks
that's awesome yeah it was great
and i battled a kid in a wheelchair that
was actually my tv debut was battling a
kid in a wheelchair
um
and
he i said uh
i said joe is much more than a comedian
in a wheelchair he's also an extreme
burden on his family
and then i one of the other ones i had
was uh is uh i was like uh joe's um uh
joe's a mexican comic or joe's
joe's family's mexican and his wife's
not
they're mad at him
oh [ __ ] how far we got what it was like
oh joe's family's mad at her because she
picked a vegetable or something like
that was she picking or oh yeah oh yeah
and i remember i was like uh
i was like they're just mad because they
picked fruits and she picked a vegetable
it was like oh that was this beautiful
was the through line yeah it was it was
amazing so it was a lot of stuff like
that and like my mom was so worried that
i was gonna get in trouble for battling
a kid in a wheelchair
and uh it ended up getting me on the tv
show got blew up yeah but that uh
episode ended up getting pulled my my tv
debut ended up getting pulled because
crystalline got canceled
[Laughter]
crystalia was the judge on my episode
and then uh oh christolya yeah yeah so
they canceled it so they pulled my tv
debut and
greg's tvw and like a bunch of other
people's and like this is the thing that
was so funny to me was like they pulled
his episode which is like i get why they
had to do
they had to show that they
did something right but they also like
canceled the tv debut of like six comics
from marginalized communities you know
what i mean yeah so it's just kind of
like i don't know it was just a weird
thing that happened
but they you know before somebody got in
in
what was in hot water like nobody ever
tried to cancel anybody
yeah it's like
i think consequences are fine
but the act of like canceling someone
you know what i mean is just such an odd
thing but also i truly don't think
comics get cancelled every comic that
i've seen get cancelled has just sold
tickets out on the road which is our
ultimate goal you know what i mean yeah
it looks like no one gets cancelled
based on actual material like if they do
[ __ ] sort of inside that crimes yeah
yeah well i mean like
i mean i want to keep talking about it
but uh uh you know what's his name
he's going to be fine he's still going
to be able to tour he's got his podcast
everything he's probably never able to
do tv anymore which is
that's kind of like you get a timeout
from tv you get a strong patreon you got
a stream yeah you get a like a solid
patreon falling
which you know
yeah it depends on what you yeah you're
just working in another area yeah
but
i'm lucky i had a confirmed job you know
yeah those are things you never have to
deal with also now that we're talking uh
where are we on that uh uh brian landry
case how are you uh
do you uh you gotta need a dog yeah the
dog's gonna find him
where is he though
no i don't think he's dead you know
unless he committed suicide and i doubt
it
he's got too big of an ego to do that
because he got away with everything but
i think he's out in the swamps you know
by his house he knows the area you know
the people are it sounds like he's a
survivalist and it's hard to track over
there
and with no electronic surveillance or
no hints or anything else
uh i find it difficult uh did you follow
them or anything before they climb oh uh
no i didn't follow him but that's like
my closing joke right now
is making fun of not making fun of but
talking about that in their relationship
yeah because i just related it to my
relationship where it was just kind of
like i've been with my wife for like 10
years and whenever we see something like
that happen we immediately are just like
do you think you can get away with
killing me you know what i mean like we
just asked
each other stupid questions like that i
mean and uh yeah but i've just been
talking about it on stage it's been a
lot of fun
um the response has been pretty good a
lot of o's and odds but then a lot of
people laugh what did you think of the
way that the police spoke to her and the
way the police spoke to him it was it
it's it for me it felt like i was
watching a cop have to deal with an
argument between a couple and he was
just like ugh you know what i mean but
that's what that's what it kind of felt
like and then the argument itself
watching them it felt like an argument
between such a young couple like a
couple have been you know i mean he was
like she didn't
she goes he didn't believe that i could
be a travel blogger and i was like
that's such
that's such a i've been in a fight with
my girlfriend for two years you know
what i mean like you're never gonna make
it like i've been in that fight so many
times
but it's like just lie to them that's a
good one it sounds to me like some cop
was lazy because they even said
definitively you know hey somebody's
gotta go you know if there's
somebody's got to go and somebody just
found a way to
you know
okay both go your separate ways or
everything's going to be okay you say
it's going to be all right we'll let you
go we don't have to do this and so they
were just lazy didn't want to write
paper and didn't want to go through the
well the 911 call said that that guy was
some guy called in and said hey there's
this guy slapping his girlfriend yeah
okay so when when they pulled him out of
the car and started to talk all of a
sudden
it turned into her being him yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was it was a very like i
was like this seems like a very weird
like yeah lazy they were trying to move
move them along i think yeah just go
don't write paper there's a boyfriend it
happens all the time but only now the
law is very definitive yeah you know you
got to take they didn't take action they
take responsibility
no they haven't yet yeah the compromise
i think it's like one
like no matter what it is if it's
domestic anything one person has to yeah
if there's any evidence of physical
contact yes
and there was and they didn't they let
it go and so i think eventually when all
this is over
somebody's going to get sued there's
going to be problems
with the yeah the dust settles how long
after that video that did did he murder
her if he did i think it was like a week
later yeah yeah yeah
so it'll it's not going away we see that
young too seeing this yeah he was like
what the early 30s early 30s early 20s
yeah he didn't seem like he was younger
yeah i mean he looked like an old piece
of [ __ ] but he was like yeah he was like
bald and stuff the whole time i looked
at that relationship i was like she
could do better
that's what they tell you
she had a shot at me
[Laughter]
your girl there i don't know who that
message
but you know you know um
man i think i said this before you know
when i was we were like 13 or 14 in the
neighborhood there was a guy who was
maybe 19 or 20 around there and he was
having sex with somebody at his job but
she was married
and so she was older she was probably 30
he was probably 19. and he would talk to
us about it on the porch
and we'd be sitting there we're 14 we're
like wow
and then what and uh
and one day somebody knocked at the door
and that guy opened it and her husband
shot him through this
through the screen hit him in the chest
and dropped him right there holy [ __ ]
yeah man people that was a long time
that was [ __ ] 1975
oh wow damn and we went over there
because the police came that the door
was open you could see the hole you
could see his shoes the same shoes he
was wearing when he was talking to us
he was
was that the first time you were like
around a murder yeah yeah i was i
remember i was like 13 and uh a couple
across the street from where i was
staying uh murder-suicided themselves
yeah yeah yeah because one of them was
like had like a life-threatening illness
and was like i can't live without you
and then they just [ __ ] both went out
and i was like holy [ __ ]
yeah
i think the tough ones are yeah i told
my mother-in-law if i get that bad if i
get that desperate i'm gonna kill your
wife kill your daughter because i don't
want her to see me suffer
[Laughter]
she didn't think it was funny
that's pretty good man that's hilarious
you need 120 more of those
[Laughter]
yeah
i asked my wife if she could kill me and
she said absolutely
she said uh your hands are normal no she
said uh she was like you never pay
attention to what i feed you and i was
like oh my god i was like you've thought
of that i will not
yeah
it's not easy i don't think to to me to
me
disposing of the body would be
like when you go to the market and tell
you how much chicken you grab
in five minutes you're running around
and you're trying to get something done
but
you're touching things yeah
right yeah i asked my wife i was like do
you think i could kill you and she said
no
because
killing someone and getting away with it
requires patience
like a thought out plan and
follow-through which i apparently have
not known
she was like you have none of those
things [ __ ] beautiful and i was like
okay that's hilarious yeah
it goes on every day and the husband's
always a prime suspect always and they
still do it
yeah
that's why they're the prime suspect
they can't they always they still do it
because in their
the i mean they're not going to get away
with it but i don't know if they see a
little a little bit of light
maybe yeah i don't think you can
somebody can withstand that
the conversation with the police
officers the fbi the guilty i just look
i can't look into anybody else's mind
look at myself
and
i know
i could kill
if i wanted you know like my wife damn i
i know i could
i could do it
yes
can we go at the time i could join in
ever get away with it because the guilt
it hit me oh you know you talk to
somebody that's so eventually eventually
you
you have to talk and that's what gets
killer scott they talk oh yeah i like
how you're like you're like i can
absolutely do the act of killing my wife
but it's the guilt that would make me
feel bad i was like that's so funny use
let me clarify i just use that as an
example
means but not the motive yeah
your behavior changes 50 years i'm in it
it's too late no i get it but then your
behavior changes and even being natural
is the most unnatural thing it is
you know how they do it i i have no idea
gone baby was one of my favorite movies
did you watch that one baby gun dude no
uh yeah it was with the lady who fakes
her own kidnapping uh gone girl gone
girl what am i thinking gone baby oh i'm
thinking of a song gone girl with um
[ __ ] ben affleck and roseman pike
yeah
it's amazing it's a really fantastic
based on a book you see matt siegman oh
that was a great one
actually i cried during that one massive
man was yeah i cried during a lot of
movies i i'm the same
nicholas cage has ocd yep and sam
rockwell right and sam rockwell and they
play these two guys that call people up
and they say
you just wanna
these those water filter systems
and then they come over to your house
they get they get you talking and you
write a check for like ten dollars then
you just take the the information off
the check
and they were ripping people off yeah
they were con men it was great
with the suits and the whole then they
would go back
and
pretend that they were
the police yeah yeah yeah and then i
think they would they would case the
house and then steal it or steal like
break back in yeah yeah see now i don't
want to watch a movie you guys told me
all about that
that's a small bro trust me the twist
when you find out the robots it's pretty
great that's just the tease that fly
[Laughter]
but yeah that's and this is pretty good
too by the way
are you feeling
oh yeah no these this so it's the
chocolate that's uh that's oh now i'm
feeling it too i just the full hundred
yeah
yeah i did a hundred yeah damn dude is
that like a whole container one of these
things yeah yeah ten balls
yeah you know try it out
trouble watch the dodgers do it tonight
dude oh yeah does uh can it all put you
to sleep or it has to be like
independence but can for me which one oh
yeah yeah what would be the edibles the
edibles whichever animals you take
they'll put you to sleep wow yeah yeah
yeah i think that's better man i got to
finish watching dodger game yeah
tonight
that's tied right now right the series
101 yeah yep
it's in our favor now where did you see
tom cruise that picture of tom cruise
that's so funny looks like mcdonald's
[ __ ] is that man what is that no idea
yeah somebody told me he's playing santa
claus that's [ __ ] that's that's why
i should tell people hey maybe put some
weight on oh yeah i'm playing santa
claus
get my new show do you have a new show
yeah that's why i'm getting this weight
you're going on tour too soon right i
think i have been
yeah you haven't yeah you just think you
have been here
yeah he's got a full face huh yeah
yeah
sure does tommy cruz is the filler is
that filler or that's just him
i don't know man i even questioned they
put his name up there you know maybe i i
first when i saw it i thought it was a
lookalike you know somebody resembled
him and then they put his name down the
bottom it didn't [ __ ] look like and
it he looked big people got to be
tripping off that what could that be
could be kidney disease liver kidney
swollen face he also seems like the kind
of guy that george lopez taco's okay
if something happens he doesn't seem
like the kind of celebrity that would
like tell everybody it would just like
happen and then people were like oh [ __ ]
and you have to go to a doctor with a
scientologist well yeah they don't
really believe in doctors too
they don't have have you have you just
like oh my psychologists right
fascinating so there's um going clear
which is an amazing documentary i saw
that you see going clear on hbo is that
the one with uh lee rimmey yeah
no no no no no that's uh um that's her
shot matt bloomfield yeah yeah matt
bloomfield did that okay no i didn't see
it so
like most scientologists believe that
once you get to the highest level
scientology you reach like this level of
i can't what's the best way like
spirituality that you no longer get sick
or anything like that you just can cure
yourself with your thoughts that's kind
of the deal that's what happened with i
think leah remini's mom no right no no
that was someone else in scientology um
one of the people that defected their
mom was in a super high level and died
and she wasn't supposed to because she
was at this high level of scientology
and then that's when people start to
like
like leave because they're like oh this
is [ __ ]
that's what it took huh yeah yeah
they got a lot of yeah that's a big
business man clear water you've been a
clear water uh no they have a base in
temecula though
or no my bad hemet uh hem is that the
one where the they go to punish you yep
yep i've driven by it yeah it's a huge
huge compound it's crazy
so they send you over there and then you
become
well we have to be careful with it yeah
become someone who works for a low wage
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's probably
gonna be the one thing that's gonna get
us yeah we're all gonna get [ __ ]
murdered um they yeah so you sign like a
lifelong contract and you get paid low
wages and then if you don't follow and
then you get punished you get sent to
hemet where it's like a reprogramming
kind of deal
yeah is it gold base i think so yes
they've been arrested yeah and they've
been around
a long time a lot of actors are in it
they have some prime uh real estate
a lot of a lot of a lot of property i
mean the visual of gold base is like an
oasis in the desert on this picture oh
absolutely but it is not annoying
anything but yeah have you do you know
anybody that's a scientologist um no but
i would say like if it's like if there's
something bad so this is the best part
about uh young comics there's two young
comics that were door guys at the store
named abby roberge and arimanus
they
walked into the scientology building
just to see how far they could get one
day
and uh they ended up getting to like
going to an elevator and getting all the
way down and they walked into like a
photo shoot and one of the people there
was like are you guys here for the photo
shoot and they're like yeah so they
dressed up in scientology stuff and they
were in the scientology like monthly
magazine that gets made and sent to all
the scientologists so they were on like
one of it was hysterical
yeah insane that's hilarious but they go
down there and go yeah they got down
there and they were able to get out but
uh after a while they're like yeah the
scientology museum is pretty cool and i
was like oh okay now i'm like i'm not
hanging out with you for the next few
months because i don't know if you got
god ari man will do anything ari mantis
is a very funny comic he will absolutely
do anything for a joke and that was one
of the funniest things he did i think
what was the thing he did with his mom's
car oh i don't know he gave away one of
his mom's cars on craigslist
so when his parents came home they were
like what the hell and they yeah he gave
away like
he gave away their cars on craigslist
there's no other way to say it it was
pretty and he filmed it it was hilarious
man
yeah did they give him back it was
absolutely no he he comes from like a
pretty rich family so
they didn't want it
no yeah no they think they just bought
new cars but like they were not happy
like his mom was not did not think it
was funny at all oh you don't say yeah
this guy wally uh out there by mission
hills where i grew up and you know i was
sitting for this couple and they had
horses
kind of like a ranch style house and he
sold one of their horses
[Laughter]
amazing holy [ __ ] that's so great and
they're like what did you say
because when they got home no i told
them i sold their horse
and had they take it [ __ ]
they fired them and they try to get the
horse back but they're like hey man
come with me it was a deal oh my god
that's sold
me [ __ ] dude had somebody come in and
take them around right over what do you
think yeah i'll take them they're like
the truck up put them in the trailer and
took them that's so great i love stories
like that i was i was a guy who wouldn't
do
i wouldn't do pranks man you wouldn't no
no i was really kind of
you know
but there's some pretty good pranks so
huh oh yeah
absolutely do you guys want comfortable
pranks on each other oh yeah
[Laughter]
we pulled this one where we put
nevermind i'm not gonna make that joke
somebody in the trunk
yeah yeah yeah we used to ride around in
the trunk as kids
did you
love them
no
[ __ ] being pulled over no hey you
can't do that to that kid yeah nothing
just got it back in the day you used to
be able to cast your checks at bars
yeah my dad would tell stories about how
on payday uh his mom and dad would drive
to the bar and be like hey we gotta go
cash your paychecks and they'd be in
there for like an hour and a half
and uh they'd just be outside in the
street like playing by the car they're
like we didn't think anything was wrong
i was like yeah that's i think that's
abuse they used to have more of those
little bars on this little like uh yeah
with all darkness yeah local cantinas
right there around the body they'd all
go in there
i remember hearing stories
that my swagger would go in there and my
wife would have to go in there hey mom
send me here pick get the check
wow that's true yeah during the day too
or if there's half day
uh the rest of the afternoon they'd be
at the
dude drop in the top hat
one of my friends uh mom uh
was at the top hat on uh laurel canyon
near uh fox
and
she came into a liquor store and we were
going walking home from school and she
goes give me a ride home boys we're like
14.
we kind of don't know how to drive it's
just straight down there so we gave her
ride home and when she was looking for
her keys a gun fell out of her purse oh
my god she's like where are my keys
i'm going for all oh give me that [ __ ]
give me that on the
and she was one of those ladies that
had a 38. she was packing packing dude
that's and we drove her home
and then we had to walk [ __ ] 10 miles
back we got [ __ ] in that deal we were
five minutes away from home where we
left her in the car like how do we get
back she found she's asleep
they started walking out you know let
you keep the gun that's crazy [ __ ] no
you took that thing but now we're like
way in the [ __ ] out here terrorists now
back to michigan hills
no good deed
so if people want to get some of this
where is there an instagram page oh yeah
uh punch edibles on instagram punch
extracts uh you can also check it out
buds and roses a lot of weed maps is the
best one you can just search and then um
puffco's got a great website uh
puffco.com you can follow me on
instagram i plug these guys all the time
but yeah uh then i work for toptree uh
and yep that's it man you can make money
in this business huh yeah i mean i've
i've been able to pay my rent it's been
pretty great yeah that's awesome thanks
for coming in dude dude thank you so
much uh i appreciate it um yeah going on
tour is it cool if i play with you oh
yeah and hit the podcast because you
haven't said it oh yeah sorry dude i'm
i'm high too you know i got a podcast
called peaked uh it's peak tv on
instagram i'm going on tour october 17th
through the 21st uh denver colorado
comedy works uh portland oregon the
funny house lounge uh oh i should
remember the other ones uh san jose
improv and then the los angeles uh
hollywood melrose improv so yeah very
excited brian simpson
um rachel wolfson you know what i'm
gonna come and see you man one of those
days i'm gonna try
but you know you talk about those days
at the comedy store when i was there
and the uh
the main room the original room is the
one on top and then the main room is the
big one so you would hear um
like just this [ __ ] roar and there
was a door to go to the bathroom i'd
like to hit three little steps up and
about you open the door and a straight
shot to the stage a right place in the
middle of the door robin williams is up
there with his hair he's got the rainbow
uh suspenders like i guess he might have
come from paramount morgan mindy and he
had the khaki pants on and he was like
whoo he had this chick with the and
you're like [ __ ] man yeah the great's
there man dude they just went up there
no introduction just walked down
i got to meet him uh a year before he
passed away and then i got to meet jim
carrey a year when i was working at the
store yeah i was checking ids and he got
to we got to talk it was great
uh deep thinker jim carrey man yeah you
wouldn't think uh
that he would be because he started his
career so so well but
yeah
very deep thinker it was it was very
interesting talking to him he told us
the whole story the check
um just i mean i was very lucky to be in
the circle of comics he was talking to
when he was because he had just came
back to the store and had been a while
yeah so he kind of was like reminiscing
and talking everything it was man it was
powerful you could feel it yeah oh yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] the company store
had some great
everybody's been through there yeah
great memories and if you've never been
you should go through i love it
it's the way i feel when i round these
guys
it's awesome yeah the golf tournament
last week was
it was it was awesome it was it was
great i was nervous coming out here to
see george meeting doing the show
i told george over there uh
at the tournament when i left my house i
told my wife i said i'm nervous
he said what are you nervous for you've
done this [ __ ] yeah you've gone out with
i said no but i mean these are all rich
people they got a lot of bucks i'm not a
nurse you know
and they're crowds i don't know how i'm
going to act i don't know what i'm
supposed to do
i don't want to get in in your way and
so i was nervous until i got there and
then once i got there
it it was nice people treated me good
yeah
and it was all good it was probably
uh in my adult life other than my family
it was probably one of the best days
i've ever had oh god
everybody loved to have you there dude i
couldn't see it i couldn't talk enough
to my kids to my
everybody's checking with me it was good
they're beautiful all right
here we are baby thank you so much thank
you thank you dream come true doug right
on
thank you pleasure
you